So our answer to the last quiz would've been a lot easier
to read and a lot more useful if we used names to
keep track of values, instead of writing out those big numbers, especially
numbers as big as the speed of light. Python provides a way
to do it. It's called the Variable. We can use the variable
to create a name and use that name to refer to a
variable. So the way to introduce a variable is using an assignment
statement. And an assignment statement looks like this. We have a name,
followed by an equal symbol, followed by an expression. After
the assignment statement, the name that was on the left side
refers to the value that the expression has. The name
can be any sequence of letters and numbers, as well as
underscores, as long as it starts with a letter or
an underscore. So here's an example, we could create the name,
speed_of_light, and we can assign to it the value of the
speed of light in meters per second. So after that assignment,
the name speed_of_light refers to that value. One way to
think of that is to have an arrow, so we can
have the name speed_of_light, and that's a name which refers to
a value. And the value it refers to is this long
value, which is the speed of light in meters per
second. So once we've done the assignment, we can use the
name and the value of the name is the value that
it refers to. In this case it's the speed of light
in meters per second. So let's try that in the Python interpreter.
So here we've introduced the variable speed of light and we've assigned to it
the value 299,792,458, the speed of light in meters per second.
And now we've got that, assign it a variable.
Instead of having to type out that whole number, we
can use it directly. When we print out the
speed of light, it will be the value that that
name refers to. So we'll see, instead of seeing
speed of light, we'll see the 299 million value here.
We can use in expressions as well. So if we
want to convert it into centimeters instead of meters, we
can multiply by 100 and now we see the result
is the speed of light in centimeters per second. So
let's define another variable. This one will define billionth, which
means 1 divided by 1,000,000,000. That's hard enough to remember
how many zeros to type, so it's nice to
have that in a variable. And now we can define
nanostick, which is the length of Grace Hopper's nanostick,
as the speed of light times a billionth. That would
be the length of the nanostick in meters. If
we want it in centimeters, we can multiply by 100.
And so now we've defined a variable, nanostick, which is
the length light travels in a nanosecond, in centimeters, and
we can print that out. So, variables are really useful. They're going to
make our programs a lot easier to understand. They also mean that we can
use the same expression, changing the
values of the variables to compute different
things. So, now it's time for a quiz to see if you understand variables.